today's one minute monday is take a risk
i have a challenge for you today i want
you to take a risk and step outside your
comfort zone because we live in this
bubble you live in this world where
everything is safe and comfortable and
you do the things that you're used to
doing and that you're good at where if
you want to have happiness you want to
have success you want to have freedom
you want to achieve your big goals you
want to change the world you want to
have an impact on people you can't stay
in this little bubble you got to expand
and how you get there is by continually
stretching your comfort zone and taking
risks now i'm not talking about you know
putting all your money and taking out a
mortgage and launching a business okay
you don't have to take a huge financial
risk just do things that make you feel
uncomfortable
so what i did was i i released a video
of me singing lean on me my sister asked
on twitter somebody posted a video of
lean on me for a secret project i'm
doing and i thought you know what
i'm not a singer
but i'm gonna do this for her because
it's a chance to stretch my comfort zone
and the video you know it wasn't great
okay it wasn't a great video but it's
not that bad it's not terrible and i was
super nervous making it and putting it
up but it's there and i'm happy i did it
and i feel like i stretched i want you
to stretch yourself today i want you to
take a risk and it could be something
small
talk to somebody a stranger on the
elevator you would normally talk to make
an important business phone call that
you need to make for your company to
help it grow
say i'm sorry to somebody who you you've
hurt in the past and you feel guilty
about just take a risk step outside your
comfort zone and start to stretch
yourself when you guys do it leave it in
the comments below i want to know what
you're doing share it with us i'll be
your cheerleader to support you and help
you get this thing going take your risk
believe
you